ho due confessa
la prima è che non sono il tecnico dei
video
la seconda è che sono un disastro con le
parole ed è forse per questo che ho
preferito la musica il sound design e
successivamente l'informatica alla
all'italiano racconta un piccolo
aneddoto della mia storia di bambino io
sono uno di quei bambini fortunati un po
geek un po nerd che alla fine degli anni
70 ha avuto a disposizione uno zio
fisico e le sue calcolatrici mi ricordo
benissimo una bellissima calcolatrice
sharp programmabile in basic che lui mi
ha consegnato dicendo mi potresti fare
il programma di contabilità per la zia e
io a codice scritto su un foglio di
carta
ho cominciato pian piano a scrivere in
questi forini piccoli nel software per
la zia debba gando la notte con lo zio
per riuscire a fare contenta appunto la
zia miria mi riaggancio a alle memorie
alle mie memorie di bambino perché due
giorni fa ho lanciato un piccolo contest
chiesto aiuto ai miei amici di facebook
e gli ho chiesto di descrivervi il loro
primo ricordo sonoro normalmente tutti
siamo abituati ad avere un ricordo
visivo siamo abituati ad avere un
ricordo un sogno qualcosa che è nella
memoria in bianco e nero ma poche volte
ci focalizziamo sulla questione sonora
sulla questione del della consapevolezza
del suono
cito uno dei commenti perché di un'amica
di sandra una mia amica musicista
materana che ha mi ha mandato questo
ricordo mi ha detto io sentivo da
bambina le campane dei tre campanili che
mi svegliavano la mattina e mi descrive
una cosa bellissima per me perché questi
sono i feedback sonori sono le cose che
sono le informazioni che sono dentro ai
suoni mi ha descritto anche che riusciva
a capire se la notte avevano indicato
dal suono delle campane dicendo che
appunto sarebbero durate meno
oggi mi sono dato un challenge è un po
un po difficile perché io ci provo
perché abbiamo pochi minuti e perché
sono anche un po un po pazzo oltre che
il challenger questo io vorrei spiegarvi
partendo dal primo suono della storia
del nostro universo dal big bang
vorrei spiegarvi che cos'è suono e che
cosa diventa quando il suono viene
digitalizzato cioè quando il suono entra
dentro una cosa che può parlare con noi
attraverso appunto il linguaggio sonoro
ben venga
faccio una domanda secondo voi il big
bang che natura ha una natura ritmica
oppure a una natura melodica cioè è una
percussione o è un canto una percussione
un canto vi svelerò un segreto è
entrambe perché perché dipende dal punto
di vista di chi ascolta il punto di
vista del big bang che avviene in un
istante di planck è di essere impulsivo
per noi che lo ascoltiamo ma in realtà
il big bang sta ancora suonando adesso
vi faccio sentire una rappresentazione
della diciamo una sonorizzazione della
radiometria di un diciamo telescopio che
ascolta le onde radio e vi faccio
sentire come suona il big bang
come potete sentire è un glissando che
dall'acuto scende verso il grande
considerate di un impulso in informatica
in campionamento in teoria del
campionamento se analizzato
spettralmente quindi si è analizzato
guardando le frequenze di cui composto
rappresenta tutte le frequenze in un
istante
tanto che ci sono delle tecniche
informatiche si chiamano risposte
all'impulso che sono in grado di capire
come funziona presenti al riverbero di
questa stanza utilizzando uno sparo di
una pistola uno sparo di una pistola è
la somma di tutte le componenti speciali
il big bang è la somma di tutte le
componenti spettrali che dall'acuto
quindi dal d'albenga
comincia e scende verso il grave e noi
sentiamo appunto la rappresentazione di
queste onde adesso vedete questa cosa mi
hanno sconsigliato di metterla perché mi
hanno detto questa cosa poi è
difficilissima da capire
ci sono delle sinusoidi ci sono dei pi
greco quella cosa bruttissima che a
scuola fa impazzire
io però o quest'altro challenger vorrei
spiegare di questa cosa e lo faccio con
l'aiuto di una della mia assistente
questa si chiama slinky avete visto toy
story io ho preso il cane e gli ho tolto
la testa e le gambe e per questo però
bisogno di un'assistente ha bisogno di
una posso prendere un assistente posso
lo faccio sempre lezione funziona anche
perché attira l'attenzione dei miei
studenti che di solito sono maschi
allora io con questa slinky posso
spiegare un sacco di cose posso spiegare
per esempio la natura del suono prima
cosa il suono per esistere ha bisogno di
un mezzo elastico questa è una molla ed
è un mezzo elastico senza mezzo elastico
il suono non si propaga tutti i film di
fantascienza che avete visto sono dei
fake enormi perché lì nello spazio non
si sente
nulla nulla come si propaga il suono si
propaga attraverso compressione e
decompressione dell'area attenzione
vedete la figata scusatemi il termine la
figata è che questa slinky diventa anche
magicamente una corda un filosofo e
teorico della della vibrazione colui che
ha diciamo aperto a quella che si chiama
armonia delle sfere loro l'hanno
studiata moltissimo all'epoca i greci
tale pitagora ha cominciato a studiare i
moti delle corde per descrivere la rom
unicità che c'è nell'universo e l'ho
fatto appunto prendendo una corda
non racconto gli aneddoti perché
sarebbero troppo lunghi ci vorrebbero
almeno altri altri quattro interventi
però quello che voglio far vedere che
all'interno di ogni suono armonico
quindi dell'arpa del pianoforte non
della voce esistono infinite armoniche
che hanno una legge matematica la legge
matematica ed è di essere multipli di
una fondamentale
questa è la fondamentale questa la
vibrazione fondamentale che la
vibrazione più grave quella che sono più
più grave attenzione che se io adesso vi
dicessi di battere le mani a ritmo noi
potremo capire che il doppio di questo
ritmo è la seconda armonica che è questa
ok è che la terza armonica è il triplo
no è una persona adatta a ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta allora questa cosa è
fondamentale grazie posso poi stare con
me programma è la cosa fondamentale è
che è che è una delle mie dei miei must
è che non c'è per me differenza fra
ritmo e suono perché tutto è dentro a
una questione legata la trasduzione
umana
il tradimento umano che per me è
fondamentale cioè noi viviamo e
ascoltiamo in funzione di una percezione
che io chiamo tecnicamente filtro passa
basso perché ci fa sentire solo le cose
che vanno piano e lentamente e che
legata a una cosa che è legato a una
cosa diciamo atavica cioè la precisione
del ritmo in funzione della percezione
della melodia noi impariamo il ritmo
dalla dal cuore di nostra madre e lo
impariamo a tre mesi di vita
intrauterina è il primo senso che si
forma l'udito e ascoltiamo la dance che
nostra madre ci fa quando ci ha
concepito
adesso io faccio sentire un'altra cosa
questo è il battito lo riconoscete
siamo dentro l'utero è quando noi
prendiamo quel singolo battito e lo
acceleriamo ascolteremo una cosa che
[Musica]
e diventato un suono questa cosa è
legata al prossimo slide che vi mostro
lo so che non si legge ma non importa è
legata grazie è legata a due concetti a
me cari e capirete perché io ho
cominciato facendo musica e poi sono
finito a fare l'interaction designer
cioè il designer dell'interazione perché
io questa slide l'ho presa da un
bellissimo libro che è di curtis lo zsc
è un uno dei pilastri del diciamo della
musica informatica
lui fa questo questo schema e divide i
tempi musicali che sono quelle cose che
vedete sopra sopra macro mezzo sound
object micro e samp ok li divide in tre
fasce tutto quello che ha a che vedere
con il periodo quindi le ripetizioni
pensate che noi abbiamo il nostro
universo è datato più o meno in 15
milioni
visioni di m e la sua più piccola
scomposizione che quella del tempo di
planck tempo di planck è quanto ci mette
la luce a fare una costante la costante
di planck
anche qui ci vorrebbero almeno 40 tel
però si può studiare a casa ci sono
delle cose meravigliose online nessuno
sa che 0,7 di ieri 31 è la frequenza di
un anno un anno a quella frequenza ma
soprattutto che 600 millisecondi sono il
tempo che noi ci impieghiamo per
accorgersi di esserci di essere nel
presente
questa cosa si permette di imparare ci
permette di stoppare l'istinto e quindi
di insegnare all'istinto gli animali non
ce l'hanno gli animali e immediato per
gli animali e immediato la cosa che la
chiave di lettura di tutto a quei 12 r
che sono il fast freight human jester's
cosa vuol dire è il gesto che l'uomo può
ripetere più veloce fatalità coincide
con due cose 15 hearts cioè 15 frame al
secondo sono la persistenza sulla retina
i film noi non vediamo diciamo vediamo
un video continuo invece di vedere tante
diapositive perché c'è questo qui ci
sono questi 12 f 20 hertz e la soglia
tra il riconoscimento del ritmo e il
passaggio suono se noi fossimo una mosca
guardando un film penseremo di essere a
lo slideshow delle vacanze perché perché
la mosca a 200 hearts come faster
gesture questo l'ho già detto faccio un
piccolo esperimento possono torniamo
alla parte primitiva a me interessano
molto le primitive mi interessano gli
archetipi e le primitive perché lo zio
mi ha insegnato a fare reverse
engineering e quando uno scopre questa
metodologia impara le cose come
funzionano nella parte più intima e
quindi si innamora di del bere verso
ingegneri allora non ci sto provando il
primo uomo fa questo alla prima donna
poi per poi staccarsi da questo gesto
[Musica]
cioè io vedo il gesto come metafora il
suono come metafora del gesto per
suonare uno strumento bisogna applicare
dei gesti e vedo il gesto come metafora
dell'interazione senza il gesto non c'è
interazione e senza gesto noi non
possiamo comandare questa cosa
il gesto è l'archetipo è la diciamo
l'archetipo di comunicazione con le cose
ed è proprio qui che volevo introdurre
la questione legata l'internet of things
di internet of everything tutte le cose
comunicano tra loro e comunicano
probabilmente con dei suoni
quindi la domanda nasce spontanea ma noi
possiamo comunicare con le cose con i
suoni si può dc sonoro traduzione di un
gesto in sono telecomunicazioni prima
telecomunicazione della storia
morse codice morse dita che battono e
che trasformano il gesto in impulsi
elettrici che vengono riconosciuti come
codice sonoro da delle signorine
simpaticissime che traducono questo è si
può fare in borsa io sono abbastanza
vecchio per ricordare questa cosa perché
come dicevo prima
internet è arrivata subito a casa mia e
quindi io ricordo questa cosa
meravigliosa mi riporta indietro rai
alaba i dati digitali
passano attraverso il telefono con di
suoni ok è una cosa importante ho
portato nel talento
marco dica
no
se non mi sbaglio ai pm 70 94 grazie a
matt matthews max matthews parla per la
prima volta ma non sono un solo parla
[Musica]
e stato quello che ha digitalizzato
quello che ha teorizzato la teoria del
campionamento antica musicale e ha
lavorato in per laboratori su bell
laboratori saputo hanno creato appunto
questa macchina piccola citazione da
kubrick
all ibm al ibm nel finale quando
regredisce con la memoria fa questo
si viola tanto o poco più
lezione a mingo e ho la macchina che la
prima che mi ha parlato visto che al è
una voce siri è una voce cortana è una
voce stiamo passando da paradigmi di
interazione gestuali a paradigmi di
interazione naturali che sono appunto la
voce che sono appunto naturali per
l'uomo
le cose parlano suonano non leggo
l'altra sarebbe troppo lunga mi farò
sentire due esempi di significazioni di
dati perché questo è uno dei temi che mi
interessa significazione questo mio ex
allievo uno studente modello che ha
fatto una laurea specialistica in design
della comunicazione
andrea rauch e ringrazio per avermi
mandato l'esempio
questa è la soap la sanificazione del
vento solare perché la sua unificazione
elemento solare perché è successo che in
un anno sfortunato il vento solare si
arrivato un po troppo forte e abile
distrutto delle centrali elettriche
la nasa ha deciso di mandare i dati open
source al mondo per di di attenzione
perché quando quei dati cambiano
voi dovete spegnere le centrali se non
un disastro si rompono cosa di meglio
c'è che ascoltare il vento solare per
capire quando il vento solare può essere
pericoloso
[Musica]
l'ultimo volevo farvi di un progetto che
mi ha carissimo perché è un progetto che
sta portando avanti con un collega
lorenzo paglieri questo progetto si
chiama agicos e sta per gesto dal contro
surfaces o jack straw al controller
synthesis e sono delle strumenti
musicali del futuro quelle che mi remake
di star wars saranno nel bar a suonare
cosa fanno questi strumenti questi
strumenti sono in grado di captare i
gesti con cui tocco delle superfici e
sono in grado di tramutare quei gesti
imparando da quei gesti mappati su dei
modelli fisici quindi delle simulazioni
di strumenti reali e permettono di
suonare appunto a cose che noi suonare
tamente utilizzando appunto una
mappatura dei gesti
lascio il commento al video che è più
esplicativo ciampolini è un
percussionista dell'esame l'inter
contemporanee che suona agicos
[Musica]
scrittori
questo è il prototipo è stato fatto
all'irc a mo di parigi che è uno dei
centri più grossi di musica elettronica
ed è stato fatto appunto con descrittori
infatti da un amico e modellistica è
questo motore di sintesi per sintesi
modelli fisici
io ho finito però volevo farvi una
richiesta soprattutto a quelli che
stanno per avere figli o li avranno
fate di studiare musica perché la musica
apre all'universo
[Applauso]